well my friends today is such an
important show that I actually got a
haircut for today's show
um the right wing is now attacking John
fetterman for his stroke and yet they
continue to say absolutely nothing about
Herschel Walker's complete inability to
think or speak or coherently explain his
views on even a single issue making it
very obvious that this isn't really
about John fetterman's condition so
let's back up and kind of reset the
stage in Pennsylvania there's a very
important Senate race the Republican
nominee is television Dr Mehmet Oz the
Democratic nominee is the lieutenant
governor John fetterman John fetterman
uh had a stroke some months ago and as
part of his recovery
he is having auditory processing issues
and as a result we learned recently
during an NBC interview that when he is
interviewed he uses closed captioning
meaning that there is a voice to text
um mechanism which shows him on a screen
what he is being asked to kind of
contextualize that here's a report
explaining it and an interview he gave
using that technology another pivotal
Senate race in Pennsylvania now
considered a toss-up are Dasha Burns
spoke at Democrat John Federman in his
first in-person sit-down interview since
he suffered a stroke and Dasha this was
not a typical candidate interview
no Lester because of his stroke veterans
campaign required closed captioning
technology for this interview to
essentially read our questions as we ask
them and Lester in small talk before the
interview without captioning it wasn't
clear he was understanding our
conversation can voters stress that you
will be able to do this job on day one
yeah of course this is Pennsylvania
Democratic Senate candidate John
fetterman's first in-person sit-down
interview since a stroke sidelined him
from the campaign Trail for months that
auditory processing where I'll hear
someone speaking but sometimes they'll
be able to be precise on what exactly
that they're saying I use captioning his
campaign required that he be allowed to
use a transcription program on his
computer during our interview I always
thought I was pretty empathetic uh
emphatic
I think I was very excuse me empathetic
uh you know that's an example of the
stroke empathetic all right so you get
the picture now I am not going to
pretend for a second that this is a
non-issue
what we are told by doctors is that this
is not a cognitive issue
of fetterman understanding concepts but
that it is an auditory processing issue
which often takes time to get back to
normal for someone who has suffered a
stroke in other words it's turning the
audio into meaningful messages in his
brain now the right many on the right
are saying he should just withdraw
immediately and in fact as if this is
going to be a fair conversation Fox
Business host Maria Bartiromo had
fetterman's opponent Mehmet Oz on and
she said the following well it's also
very questionable to understand the need
to for this computer to be with him and
how is he going to make decisions about
Pennsylvania and fight for the
Pennsylvanian people if in fact he needs
to have a device
alongside him so I mean is this just all
the time he needs that device now by the
way Maria Bartiromo can't even do a TV
show without a teleprompter and an
earpiece where producers can talk to her
so it's it's kind of a weird direction
to go just during an interview I don't
understand
no one knows we've not been actually
exposed to this before it's the first
in-person interview here we are you know
less than a month before the election
and I've been asking John fetterman to
answer questions on the campaign Trail
initially he wasn't even on the campaign
Trail for the first couple months but
answer questions from voters answer
questions from reporters while you're
actually campaigning that's what we
normally do in a democracy and the
concern of course is that if you don't
ever leave your home and answer
questions we don't know the answers to
the questions you're asking all right so
this is the this is the approach that
they're going with here the reality is
that while we can be concerned about
fetterman's recovery Oz is so dangerous
and so unqualified and so pathetic that
of course Pennsylvania voters should
still vote for John Federman if indeed
what we are being told by doctors about
fetterman's condition is wrong or his
recovery goes in a different way than
predicted
I'm thinking ahead many steps but he
could resign and hopefully then
Democratic governor Josh Shapiro can
select the replacement until the next
election
Oz has no business even being in this
race and so there is really no choice to
be made here now here's John fetterman's
take on all this will you be releasing
updated information from your doctor on
your health before November 8th
I would say that if there was anything
or whatever I I absolutely would have
updated that you know other than the
progress that I've made it's it's
evident now I certainly not have would
have been able to sit in front of you uh
back in May or in June you know or or
July because they recovered the kind of
recovery that I need in order to be
absolutely uh whatever getting better
and better and I think the ultimate
kinds of transparency is to be in front
of thousands of people on a stage not
using a teleprompter most often kinds of
politicians use a teleprompter but
nobody wonders if he or she is able to
do the job or anything like that uh and
it's simply about that that's how that's
the kind of campaign that I run on so
listen we can all be honest and
recognize whoop that uh that this is not
the same John fetterman right now from
before the stroke we can also understand
that there's not really a choice here
where oh fetterman had a stroke so we're
going to vote for the completely
clueless unqualified hypocrite Mehmet Oz
that doesn't make any sense either and
the right very uh in a very contrived
way talking about this in the context of
fetterman but yet they don't even
mention that Herschel Walker the
Republican candidate in Georgia cannot
speak cannot think lies endlessly and
you can't tell if he's disoriented or
deliberately lying or what they are
total Hypocrites and if you are going to
raise these questions about fetterman
now where have you been for a year on
Herschel Walker who is an embarrassment
to the mere concept of a candidacy let's
talk a little bit about Herschel Walker
next